I really like the galaxy s5 II just like
with the new s10 phone Samsung is really
stepping it up but unlike the s10 and
SNe
I really can't recommend this tablet
even though I enjoyed using it quite a
bit the value proposition is fairly high
when you look at the features storage
and price $399 for a ten and a half inch
tablet that has a gorgeous high-res OLED
display 64 gigabytes of storage with the
option to easily and affordably add more
with its micro SD card slot and the same
great fingerprint scanner found in the
esta knee holding it in your hand feels
fantastic the front looks like an iPad
pro copy with its thin black bezels that
are symmetrical all around and with
rounded corners the edges start out flat
then take on a subtle curve which
actually makes it more comfortable in
the hand than both the iPad air and the
pro it weighs only 400 grams and coupled
with a five and a half millimeter
thinness it feels almost weightless in
the hand all of this sounds fantastic so
far so where are the downsides the
biggest one is at the heart of the s5 II
and that's the processor the Snapdragon
670 isn't an old chip but it's an a cord
that comes in low to mid-level
smartphones Geekbench for multi-core
scores are similar to the 2018 budget
iPad that could be found new for $250
but when we look at single core the s5
each cores half of that iPad and about a
third of the ar3
the story is similar with graphics but
what does this mean in the real world
well in a world where $1000 Android
smartphones have occasional glitches and
slowdowns imagine the same software but
with a much slower processor when it
comes time for fun be ready for a poor
graphical experience and choppy playback
Fortnight defaulted to the lowest
settings and wouldn't let me change it
and even then playback was choppy which
will definitely hinder your performance
you can check out my full gaming
comparison right over here where this
tablet really shines is watching movies
and surfing the web and that's mainly
what I ended up using it for even though
the CPU is weak that doesn't really
hinder it for these tasks browsing is
really smooth and the sharp bright
display is great to look at the 16 by 10
ratio compared to 4 by 3 means that
black bars are kept to a minimum when
standard content is viewed and the quad
speakers are shockingly loud while it
doesn't sound as good as the new iPad
pros it's definitely still great and is
actually louder in the iPad air can't
even compete
[Music]
being an oled screen the contrast ratio
is awesome and unlike the iPads even the
pro youtube will let you stream in 1440p
which maximizes the display and gives
you such a nice looking image all of
that coupled with a cheap expandable
storage for downloads makes this
experience so good that I think it's
probably the best tablet for watching
videos if you want to get a little bit
of work done Samsung does tell a $130
keyboard accessory but it's kind of
mediocre I typed for at least an hour
and even though I got used to it it's
still hard to use if only Samsung made
the keys slightly wider that would have
made for a much better experience Apple
charges more for their keyboards but the
quality is better with more
adjustability and the typing experience
is on another level a secret weapon of
the s5 EE is Dex a PC like interface
that can now be used without a display
this is great if you want to be very
flexible with multitasking and unlike
the iPads you can use a mouse which is
fantastic plugging into a larger display
and a better Bluetooth keyboard really
makes us a workhorse for research and
typing but I think there's not really
that many that will utilize this of
course with a Android you can organize
your files however you'd like and
archive them too unlike Apple's lockdown
iOS it really is a shame that so many
Android apps aren't optimized for
tablets some wouldn't let me use their
keyboards while others wouldn't even go
into landscape mode and honestly I don't
know if this will ever change since the
Android tablet market share is so low
developers aren't really incentivized to
update their apps this brings me to my
main question in a world of iPads does
the s5 e have room to compete yes I
think so but the slot is very small if
you're someone that wants a tablet for
watching videos surfing the web the s5 e
is absolutely fantastic
but even then I wish Samsung spent a
little more money on the processor to
make it smoother and more future-proof
but for almost everyone else whether you
want to get some work done you want to
type you want a game I would say you
should wait for the S type if you want
Android or if you want to just go with
the flow go and buy an iPad like almost
everybody else does and you'll have
access to a ton of great apps a great
screen and great performance thank you
guys for watching click the circle above
if you want to subscribe to see more
videos like this one and also that
little notification Bell check out our
s5 e vs iPad air compares
and gaming videos right over here this
been max max sec and I'll see you in the
next one